CBS TV news anchor Jeff Glor is outside
Stoneman Douglas hi Jeff good morning
Nora good morning once again to you the
school behind me is remains a crime
scene this morning it will remain closed
the rest of this week as investigators
search for clues students who went to
school with Nick crews say there were
warning signs and earlier today I spoke
to an attorney had a revealing interview
with an attorney for the family that
recently took crews in I started by
asking how he came to live with them his
mother died in the first part of
November last year and he really had no
place to go
he knew my clients son they met had
Douglas high school they've known each
other for a while and they just
naturally took him into their home to
help him tell me about Nick Cruz I don't
know a lot about him this family knew
him pretty well as a kid who was a
little depressed because his mom had
died had some minor problems at school
but they were helping him they had got
him a job at a dollar store where he was
working he was going to school to try to
get his GED and they didn't see anything
like this coming is he cooperating with
police yes we were met with him last
night gave him full statements showed
him cell phones that police have told us
that the family and the son not target
to the investigation not suspects they
didn't know anything about this prior to
they're just as grief-stricken as
everybody else the young man was at this
school yesterday when the shooting
occurred and he's lost some friends here
so we just don't know what to say they
right now they're in shock and they just
don't want to talk to anybody have you
spoken to Nick no you have not no have
you heard from the family about whether
they've been in touch with him they have
not he's been completely secluded from
the point in time he was arrested last
night he was at the sheriff's office the
same time we were last night being
questioned and all indicate
he's cooperating with law enforcement
did the parents experience difficulties
ever since Nick started to stay with
that did not they didn't say anything
they said he was very respectful you
know quiet a little depressed as you
would expect someone losing their mother
under those circumstances but never did
they see anything violent
you know aggression towards the school
or anybody else they are totally shocked
by this and I don't know how the process
normally works but so that how is it
that that he came to stay with them they
just offered they offered because he was
friends with their son they had met at
the school and then the son that me that
the kid really didn't have any other
place to go and and they gave him a at a
room in their house that they gave him
and you know like they say no good deed
goes unpunished but they are just as
shocked as everybody else's
grief-stricken they feel bad for Nick
that they feel more bad for everybody
else that's going through this where was
he keeping he had at least one rifle
from what police say it was he brought
it into the house and and they had
strict rules in terms of being locked in
a gun safe which is our understanding
where the where the gun was locked we
don't know how it got out but they
allowed him to have this rifle inside
the house 19 years old he's not a kid it
and he brought many of his possessions
into the home and again they didn't see
anything like this coming and they lived
we're in a rural part of Northwest not
too far about a couple miles here from
the school and what was as far as you
know what was Nick up to at this time
well he was supposed to have gone to his
adult education school that morning but
when he was woken up to go he said
something to the effect of it's
Valentine's Day I don't go to school on
Valentine's Day and they didn't think
anything of it and just left them and
they went on their business the other
young man went to school
and everybody else went to work and they
lost track of him at that point he was
in touch with the son by text but
there's nothing in those Texas we've
turned him over to the police to
indicate that he was up to anything
devious like this had the family seen
some of the photos that he had posted on
Instagram now they're just hearing about
and seeing this on the media for the
first time and they're they're pretty
shocked by it as well
Jim Lewis thanks for your time
approximate